foreign
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
I am Rosanna Lockwood coming up on
uncensored tonight yet more criminal
charges for Donald Trump this time over
the January 6 riots the Trump
spokesperson likened the new indictment
to Nazi Germany in the 30s so Will trump
supporters turn their backs on the
former commander-in-chief or rally
behind him we'll be debating that
more than 100 Trans men meanwhile have
entered a Miss Italy beauty pageants
after organizers said trans women were
not allowed to compete does this all
make a mockery of pageants and ruin the
competition for the remaining
contestants I'll talk to the organizer
of that protest
and fresh controversy loons in the
Hollywood actors strike as millionaire
a-listers go under the knife instead of
standing shoulder to shoulder with
colleagues on the picket line I'll be
talking to a surgeon two operates on the
Stars later on in the show
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored with
Rosanna Lockford
welcome to Piers morganland center with
me Rosanna Lockwood in the chat tonight
on this wet Wednesday in August I'm
afraid to say here in Britain anyway now
Deja Vu that's how I felt last night
hearing Donald Trump's been indicted
again this time on four counts including
conspiracy to defraud the United States
tampering with a witness and conspiracy
against the rights of citizens now those
are some really serious charges right
there but Deja Vu even still because we
have seen this movie before haven't we
the debates about whether we'll get a
mug shot of trump or whether he'll show
up to court in handcuffs in fact I was
in this seat for peers back in March
when the first Trump indictment was
delivered on hush Planet Money payments
to Stormy Daniels and we all then watch
together a few days later as Trump's
motorcade made its way through Manhattan
to the courthouse now back then it felt
momentous but now a few months later an
additional two indictments as well the
shock Factor Fred said it might be
starting to wear off a little there's
just so much to keep track of a myriad
of charges and legal cases and that's
exactly what the Trump campaign is
playing off casting all of this as a
politically motivated Witch Hunt to keep
the Republican Contender from getting
back into the White House but I'm here
tonight to remind you of the facts and
tell you that you should still be
shocked because since he was in office
this former president has amassed two
impeachments two arrests three
indictments 78 criminal counts overall
in three different cases that's three
criminal trials to attend in the next 18
months and the bulk of that has been as
the first for any U.S president or
indeed any leader of a democratic Nation
now is that list we just showed you a
result of a corrupt and biased federal
government conspiring against Trump as
this campaign says a form of election
interference using Trump's own social
media Network today they claimed quote
the lawlessness of these persecutions of
President Trump and his supporters is
reminiscent of Nazi Germany in the 1930s
the former Soviet Union and other
authoritarian dictatorial regimes
or that list is it is it that this man
has been so Lawless so self-interested
so power hungry and corrupt that he's
made a mockery of the U.S Constitution
now I'm clearly not American I can't
vote so I don't think my personal views
about Trump whether I like him or not
they're really not important in all this
but I do remember that day January 6
2021 so clearly as a journalist I was
working on the other side of the world
in a newsroom in Singapore watching
Trump loyalists rioting through the
halls of power in Washington DC
desperately unwilling to accept the
result of the 2020 presidential election
and Trump's defeat
now here's how the special counsel who
announced yesterday's indictment
described January 6th
the attack on our nation's capital on
January 6 2021
was an unprecedented assault on the seat
of American democracy
it's described in the indictment it was
fueled by lies
Lies by the defendant
targeted at obstructing a Bedrock
function of the U.S government
the nation's process of collecting
counting and certifying the results of
the presidential election now despite
all of this Trump still leads National
Republican polling by quite a majority
he's still a very popular man he could
still win that second run for the White
House and he is of course innocent until
proven guilty so for the rest of us
non-americans let's just watch and see
over this next year but let's just
remind ourselves this isn't Deja Vu it's
not a movie it is real and the blast
radius of these types of personalities
and debates and events they can have
Ripple effects across societies and
borders while joining me now to discuss
all this is Transformer lawyer and
author of get Trump Professor Alan
dirchowitz Allen thank you very much for
making time that we speak to you every
time there's an indictment so we should
have you on some sort of repeat uh
system here you're just the man to speak
to as a former lawyer for Trump I just
want to talk about the the nature of
this latest indictment how serious is it
and How likely is it to result in any
kind of conviction
well first of all I fundamentally
disagree with Trump's supporters who are
saying this is like Nazi Germany in the
1930s no not at all it's like the United
States in 2023 where we have uh the
weaponization of the criminal justice
system by both sides we have Republicans
today calling to the impeachment of
President Trump on spurious grounds and
we have Democrats uh criminally
Prosecuting Trump like in New York on
spurious grounds this indictment is much
more serious it goes to the heart of
democracy but it depends on the ability
of the government to prove Beyond
reasonable doubt that Trump himself
personally believed that he had lost the
election fair and square and people who
know Trump say look he really believes
he won the election he was dead wrong
and uh there's no basis for it in fact
but the First Amendment to our
constitution says there's no such thing
as a false opinion or a false idea under
the Constitution the answer to false
ideas is the marketplace of ideas not
criminal prosecution oh it's going to be
fascinating seeing how that plays out in
court that very fight there at the heart
of the right to free speech as you say
there and also the right to think
exactly what he thought but I want that
weaponization of the justice system you
just described by not just the left but
also the rights can you think that if
there have been any time in modern
American history of that kind of
precedent
yeah it happened of course during the
McCarthy period
um and uh Senator McCarthy tried to
weaponize the criminal justice system
against people on the left not only
against alleged Communists but people
who defended elected Communists and some
of the same things happening here you'll
notice that this indictment uh describes
five of Trump's lawyers as
co-conspirators uh that really does
threaten the sixth amendment uh which
provides for right of counsel lawyers
that are supposed to be creative when
they challenge elections I challenge the
2000 election on behalf of the voters of
Palm Beach County who were
disenfranchised by the butterfly ballot
we lost but nobody claimed that what we
did wasn't any way unproper challenging
elections as part of our First Amendment
right but if you know you've lost the
election and then you go and make
allegations based on completely false
statements that's not protected by the
First Amendment so this is going to be a
close case my own view is that if an
attorney general appointed by the
president is going after the president's
main rival he better have a very very
very strong case in this case I don't
think meets that standard unless there's
a Smoking Gun if there is a Smoking Gun
if somebody will credibly testify that
Trump said look I know I lost the
election but I want to corruptly try to
undo the real election and put myself in
office improperly of course that would
be very different but I think we all
doubt that we're going to see that Trump
probably convinced himself that he had
won the election and so subjectively he
had that state of mind objectively he
was dead wrong we'll go into that state
of mind uh thing shortly with another
guest but I just want to ask you on the
co-conspirative point you've picked up
and and the importance that that
testimony is going to bring if we do see
it come to court that seems to have been
the difference when it comes to this
indictment that these co-conspirators
are listed does it mean that somebody
within trumps in a circle has flipped
basically
well we don't know because I haven't
named the uh co-conspirators that we
know five of them lawyers and one of
them is a political consultant there's
been speculation that Rudy Giuliani and
others maybe ultimately indicted there's
no proof that that means anybody is
flipped but they could flip people do
flip all the time when I represent
criminal defense I tell them you have to
worry not only about your friends but
about your brother and about your mother
and about your child uh when the people
are facing life imprisonment or
disbarment or long-term imprisonment you
never know what they're going to do look
what happened to his former loyal lawyer
Cohen who flipped completely but uh uh
had some credibility issues so we're
going to see that here as well there'll
probably be some flip Witnesses and we
don't know exactly how that will play
out it's going to be fascinating Alan
thank you ever so much for your time as
ever now we're joined to further this
discussion by documentary filmmaker Alex
holder who actually obtained behind the
scenes access to the Trump family for
his documentary unprecedented also join
this conversation author and
investigative journalist David K
Johnston and pro-trump Pastor Mark Burns
great to see all of you gentlemen this
evening for us but you are all coming
into us from the United States and Alex
I want to come to you first because the
point Alan dershowitz just made about uh
Trump fully believing what he was saying
with regards to the vote count in
Georgia and he fully believed that it
was an erroneous election and that he
won does that tally up with what you saw
when you were following him around
but what I saw was a man unhinged
somebody who believes that he is going
to always be a winner at all times he
can't comprehend the idea that he lost
so what that means is that he needed to
do various things to reconcile that
belief and so he absolutely knew the
things that he was doing were absolutely
ridiculous illegal and eventually LED to
the events of January 6. I mean there is
no January 6 without Donald Trump's
consistent attack on the sanctity of the
election and then so on the one hand he
might believe that he won but that's an
an unhinged view Donald Trump isn't a
six-year-old child you know he's in his
mid 70s he knew exactly what he was
doing everyone around him essentially
was saying that he was wrong there was
absolutely no evidence to support any of
his claims his own attorney general made
that clear really a few days before I
met him in the White House and yet he
still maintained this position
regardless of the effects it would
happen so you know he knew what he was
doing was absolutely wrong but the
problem with Trump is that he thinks
that he's always right
let's uh go to mark for a bit of
reaction to that marks I know you're
very very close to former president
Trump when you hear Alex describing the
reality as some people see it but Trump
didn't see it at the time time the
factors they stood that he lost the
election but Trump believed that he won
how does that make you feel how does
that make you uh feel as a supporter of
trump
well what's really important is for us
to truly examine
um why is it that 50 plus percent of uh
the American Republican party uh and the
supporters of President Trump still
believe also that he too lost uh won the
election that he actually won the
election but but but but better than
that uh we need to be discussing why is
it that uh Joe Biden's doj has been used
uh and this latest indictment has been
used as a distraction from the Joe Biden
bribery scheme a scam
um that that's what's really should be
the topic president Trump isn't guilty
uh of the January 6 uh that he's been
falsely accused of I was there I was a
speaker I was there on the ground he's
clearly not guilty but yet this is uh
the weaponization of the Department of
Justice led by Joe Biden and his cronies
to attack the leading candidate uh for
the Republican nomination and according
to the latest poll uh if the elections
were held today a head-on match between
Joe Biden that President Trump would
come out ahead uh President Biden used
this uh as a way to create a Banana
Republican out of the greatest nation in
the world we call the United States
Postal Mark both things are possible
there is possible uh corruption
obviously within both sides here uh both
sides can be tried it is Trump that has
received the third indictment and you
talk there about the weaponization of
the justice system we were just hearing
from Alan dershowitz that he believes
it's been weaponized on both sides I
will come back to you but I want a
crossover to David K Johnston on this
idea then this weaponization do you
think that it's pure water baptism to
say that this is a sort of uh a
construct to distract away from Biden
issues
oh that's exactly what's going on here
uh first of all uh under the law you
can't turn a deaf ear just as you can't
turn a blind eye and when the Attorney
General the United States appointed by
Donald Trump when the White House
Council appointed by Donald Trump and a
whole lot of other people appointed by
Donald Trump tell him you lost the
election uh if he wants to engage in a
fantasy belief that's not a defense in a
criminal case the law about that is
eminently clear and all of the testimony
that's going to be damaging to Donald
Trump is going to come from Republicans
who he either appointed or brought in to
give him advice vice president Mike
Pence is going to be the star witness in
this case Mark Meadows Donald Trump's
chief of staff is going to be a witness
in this case there's not a single person
who's a Democrat who's like likely to be
called as a witness in this case because
the facts were all taking place in front
of other Republicans
I'll come back to you Alex uh hearing
this it feels like what we're going to
be seeing argued about is almost the
basis of what constitutes reality
um and that's going to be very tough
because Trump has set up a universe in
which he has a reality his supporters
follow that reality and then there is a
reality that others see and some would
argue that it's the Liberals that said
or Biden sees it
um it's going to be an interesting case
to watch as a documentarian surely
yeah absolutely I mean you know the idea
that we're debating reality is pretty
trumpian in a sense why I mean your your
guest before the pastor just mentioned
he was there on the 6th of January and I
mean to say that he doesn't think the
president the time was responsible I
mean did he not see what I saw which is
one of Trump's own supporters being
crushed to death on the steps of the
capital I mean that's what the rhetoric
led to and then to start talking about
Biden and you know that that's not the
point the point here is that Donald
Trump was utterly irresponsible and
dangerous you know he is a benighted
individual and yes you know I mean just
to quote Bill Barr he said that Trump
was detached from reality and of course
that's not a defense in uh in any Court
proceedings you know he's a 70 mid 70
year old man knew exactly what he was
doing and yet didn't care and then
obviously all the evidence that came out
in the January 6 committee hearings
where he just kept going and was
watching the events on January 6 on TV
and refusing to intervene until the last
minute and even then in a hard part of
the manner I mean he said on the stage
we need to fight like hell and then you
know in the preceding months he was
maintaining that position as president
Pastor Mark a chance to respond to that
because yes Pastor you did say that you
were there January's sick and Alex here
was talking about dangerous rhetoric
um and where it leads to in terms of the
actual sort of activity if we could call
it that that we saw on January the 6th
and then what do you make of the
rhetoric of likening the current justice
system and the federal government to the
Nazi party
well again as I said earlier uh you know
this is the weaponization of the
Department of Justice uh Joe Biden's
weaponization of against the leading
candidate for president of the United
States of America what is a fantasy uh
that we're not we should excuse me what
is not a fantasy um is uh Hunter Biden's
laptop what's not a fantasy is the
sitting president of the United States
of America
um took bribes right we approved the
evidence is coming out we're talking
about some rhetoric about uh that that
could be a Mis uh Mis described uh by uh
the liberal f as Donald Trump leading a
initiative to destroy January 6 but the
reality is the fact is Joe Biden is a
criminal and he is the sitting president
of the United States of America and we
are talking about Donald Trump being
indicted come on I mean
a foreign agent of another government
it's not a conspiracy it's fact right
and yet we're still talking about a
candidate the timing of it is ridiculous
the fact that this indictment is coming
out as soon as we getting close to uh
the truth about Joe Biden but yet people
are going to sleep on the fact that
we've allowed doj is leading this
investigation come on now we've given
you we've given you the platform smart
food by this to put across that point of
view and to get it out there and those
allegations and innocent till proven
guilty on all sides in this at the
moment
um I do think the public can see though
when asked about Trump and people
immediately point at Biden it does look
like distraction look David I want to
give you the last word on this and talk
about the future for the uh for Trump's
presidency but for the Republican party
where could you see it going from here
well the Republican party was warned 50
years ago that it had to get up with the
times because the demographics in
America were changing and it hasn't
changed unfortunately the Republicans
who used to call themselves The Party of
Law and Order want to defund the FBI
they have come out against all sorts of
law enforcement matters they're
supporting Donald Trump a man who
applied 12 and 13 year old children with
liquor limousines and hotel rooms
because they had money to gamble in his
casinos and I I bet the pastor doesn't
know that in one of his books Donald
spends six pages denouncing Christians
as fools idiots and Schmucks says he has
never once asked God what I do know is
that Donald Trump is the greatest
president that we've had in our lifetime
for Christians that I do know I can't
talk about what Donald Trump did
yesterday I can tell you
free it's free indeed I can't speak
about what he did years ago I can talk
about what he done today thank God
there's a speech called Amazing Grace
how sweet found
well Donald was President he declared
that his life philosophy is Revenge no
one who's a Christian can have Revenge
the life philosophy there's videotaping
him saying it uh In Our Lifetime the
fact that he he signed the executive
order
the fact that he's going out the trade
in the public school system I've never
cut anyone off on a show before but I'm
close to doing it and I know you're just
you're taking every inch that you can
get but please let David finish this
point okay thank you while he was
president at the last National Prayer
Breakfast Donald Trump once again
declared that he that revenge is his
philosophy which no Christian believes
uh Donald Trump's conduct here is going
to be either proven or not proven in a
court of law if Joe Biden has committed
crimes and so far there's zero evidence
in this exactly zero just claims then he
should be also pursued and I'm confident
that he will be but the issue on the
floor now is the indictment of Donald
Trump for his failed effort to overthrow
the government of the United States and
the evidence against him is going to
come from his own people it is going to
be his own vice president among others
who are going to testify to what he did
thank you gentlemen all of you it's been
fascinating Alex was sitting there
quietly documenting this and we do
appreciate your insights as well and
pasta as well as uh David thanks so much
two
uncensored next tonight wow the battle
for Miss Italy we're going to be talking
about that next is 100 Trans men sign up
to take part in the beauty pageant in
protesting its organizers is this
progress or is it just damaging for the
women in the contest or debate
[Music]
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City ding peers and King
cute I think it's only one for one king
he's mopped your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail not working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
Kinfolk do you believe you can win this
war but he's making me cry again we're
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
Hugh Edwards has been revealed as the
presenter at the center of the BBC
Scandal he is the most important
television presenter on the BBC that we
pay for whatever torture he may have
been going through in that in some way
is an excuse yeah for what appears to be
an abuse of power when they first got
together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth because you're
not just marrying the man you're
marrying the job that resonates with
people Elaine Maxwell agreed to be
interviewed for the very first time I
obviously wish I'd never met him
the concelli party can certainly win the
next election yes
did he say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
let it roll
[Music]
producing oil the knock-on effect is far
larger than just CO2 I nearly have
empathy when I'm speaking to them I know
I know you're probably going to vote me
after church
some of them they're easily lit
you can kiss my American ass thank you
very much
very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you that's a
threat that you'd be worried about so
are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
what does a woman make
you weren't asked to give evidence to
the grand jury I'm the only one that has
Battalion materials you don't drink
never taken drugs you're stinking Rich
should you be concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
[Music]
welcome back to uncensored now more than
100 transgender men have entered the
Miss Italy pageant in protest after that
pageant Band anyone not born female from
competing are you following along here
now this does come after the Miss
Netherlands contest crowned its first
ever male born winner trans woman now
with Miss Italy organizers saying they
would not quote jump on the glittery
bandwagon of trans activism now on
hearing those comments Italian trans man
Federico Barbarossa sparked a viral
online campaign by entering the Italy
competition himself under what's called
his dead name which is the female name
who's given a birth Freda Rica so let's
speak to Federico now joining us live
from Italy thank you very much for
making time for us and just talk to us a
little bit about why what motivated you
to do this
so you know obviously I heard about the
you know what the organizer said about
um that you know first that only uh
people assigned female at Birth to take
part in the contest uh and then
obviously I also heard that she made
that statement with the purpose of
excluding trans women you know in very
explicit way
um and so in that sense I thought that's
so dumb because you know I'm assigned
female at Birth but they wouldn't you
know dismiss my application because I'm
short they would this was my application
because I'm a man and so in that sense I
thought I'd start this uh protest
because you know
um just to show out them this sort of
like thinking is because
um yeah like I said they wouldn't have
dismissed me because I'm sure they would
have dismissed me because I'm a man and
so therefore but then you know trans
woman is not a woman so how does that
work really you know so you didn't know
you you were being cheeky you were being
playful but you were also trying to make
a point here that you disliked the way
that trans issues were being sort of
brought up and the restrictions were
being put in place in pageants
yeah exactly yeah I mean it's just um I
think it's just out of date and out of
time there's this contest uh was born
during fascism and then it was kind of
rebranded afterwards in 1946 and the I
mean obviously the roots might have
changed a little bit but obviously
um there was a clear statement made this
specific time and you know I don't
particularly
um agree with the violence of pageants
Etc personally then I think you know if
they do what's in this world then they
should be open to all women
um if they are meant for women you know
oh that's interesting because I want to
know whether you feel like you by doing
this and by galvanizing a hundred other
trans men to also do what you're doing
do you feel you've taken away from the
female contestants in the pageant
no I don't think so because you know uh
my purpose was never to take up a space
that was not my space uh I never meant
to actually take part in the contest uh
I was just you know
um I I just meant to show a loophole uh
in the system and the point is also you
know so many other uh pageants like we
saw the Netherlands
um is open to trans women so if not
women are participating is it even a
Fair competition that's what I'm asking
well I think you certainly made your
point let's bring in somebody else who
competes in these pageants she's been
listening in former love Island star and
pageant Queen Sharon gafka thank you for
making time you were listening to
Frederico just then uh Sharon what do
you make of all this
um I actually disagree with the decision
made by the Miss Italy organization I
think that there are lots of traditional
beauty pageants out there that don't
allow trans women Miss Universe is one
of those that do and I think if the Miss
Italy organizer doesn't agree with trans
women competing in beauty pageant she
should be the national director of a
competition that disallows trans women
um I personally haven't competed at Miss
Universe Great Britain four weeks ago
welcome trans women we had our first
trans women contestant at Miss
University at Clifton the international
competition allows it that Miss Universe
organization is owned by a trans woman
so she's happy to work for a trans woman
then why isn't she happy to allow trans
women to compete that's fascinating
about the ownership look I want to ask
you then seeing as you are supportive of
trans women taking part in uh
conventional beauty pageants what did
you make of the fuel or then the kind of
reaction to the Miss Netherlands winner
the other week which was a trans woman
that was Queen a crowned rather
um so I haven't seen any of the backlash
from Miss Netherlands directly so I did
make a comment basically explaining what
I just said to you guys about the
Mississippi organization taking on the
direction of another pageant and the
backlash and the trolling and the nasty
messages I got were not from other
beauty pageant contestants we're not
from other women we're actually from
cisgendered men telling me that by
allowing trans women in my space I'm
wrong when it's Myspace and my decision
to allow trans women or not and I do so
why is it men are telling me that I
shouldn't allow that yeah it's really
interesting look in terms of the beauty
pageant concept itself we just heard
from uh Frederico about what he thinks
about it when you think about it do you
think that you know if we're to compare
this to the current debate and argument
that's being had about transgender
people competing in sports particularly
trans women competing in athletic
competitions do you think there's a
clear line here when it's different
because beauty is in the eye of the
beholder a trans woman and um non-trans
women do you think they can be judged
the same in the same contest
I personally I don't feel like I'm quite
well qualified enough to talk about
trans women in sport and whether they
have a physical advantage or not but
there is no advantage in huge pageants
you know you have the same access to
everything and majority of Miss Universe
um National competitions are not based
on your physical parents for example
Miss Universe Great Britain is majority
interview
um and being a trans woman does not mean
that you're a better speaker or a better
person because you're a trans woman and
this woman also does not make you a
better candidate it's literally down to
the women that present themselves on the
day Sharon really clearly and Frederico
just before we wrap up this part of the
conversation I want to give you an
opportunity to respond to what you've
heard Sharon just say do you think do
you feel supported
yeah I definitely do feel supported and
it's great to hear someone that does
pageant uh you know saying this and it
was really interesting to say as well
the many comments uh came from Chin's
gender man which makes me immediately
think if this whole
um you know thing thing about uh trans
women about
um you know it just makes me think you
know it's all about patriarchy and
patriarchal values being held still here
uh was the move you know the world moves
forward and clearly someone likes to be
stuck in the past so maybe you know
they'll join us from the middle age on a
horse one day but
um that's clearly you know not not
happening right now but I hope I can be
a little part of this and I hope I did
something nice for my transistor without
which I would be nowhere today Frederico
Sharon you both are very generous with
your insights and your thoughts this
evening from right at the heart of the
pageant industry thanks so much
thank you well we don't have a cisgender
man for once to comment on this Esther
but we do have you yeah Esther kraku The
Voice uh of your own opinion well
listening reason listening to all of
that why why can't trans women have
their own beauty pageants why this is
the thing this is what most people I
think take issue with it's when the you
know there's a sense of entitlement like
we have the right I don't really care
about beauty pageants generally speaking
I don't know many people that do
obviously there is you know the point
that the lady made that you know your
gender doesn't play a part of it well
many beauty pageants have swimsuit
um
uh parts of the competition as well and
there is a physical element there I
don't really want to get into the
logistics of that but to say to say that
your biology plays no role come on like
that that's just disingenuous
um look I don't see why and I've
advocated this from the beginning for
sports and with shelters and anything to
do with trans individuals why can't they
have their own spaces is it is it the
fact that you know being validated in a
space that is clearly and exclusively
for biological women is the issue which
then draws into many raises many
questions that's that's my only problem
with it why can't you just have your own
beauty page well I think that raises the
key point that maybe Sharon and Federico
brought up it's that validation as you
put it so but then that's where people
take issue because you can't force
someone to validate your identity you
can't force someone to believe something
that they don't want to believe you know
for the many people on this planet a
trans woman will never be a woman period
and you know if we're talking about
tolerance and respect why doesn't the
respect go the other way why why do we
now have to pretend if people don't
believe that but you know trans Woman as
a woman and therefore seeing what is a
biological man in a dress at a beauty
pageant are we just like you know it's
like the emperor has no clothes moment
are we just supposed to pretend how do
how is that being respectful to people's
opinions it's good to have you here to
present the other side of the debate a
lack of a cisgendered man well I know
even that terms whilst people yeah men
up these days uh but it has been a
fascinated bait and stay with us as
we'll come back to you as well
uncensored next tonight fresh
controversy looms and the Hollywood
actors strike a-listers are reportedly
going under the knife instead of
standing in solidarity with their
colleagues on the picket line as surgeon
to the Stars joins us next
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
actor appears on screen like a little
fresh-faced when the Hollywood strike
ends it might not just be from a bit of
R and R some of Hollywood's Elites are
apparently making the most of the
unexpected free time they've got now to
go under the knife and that's
potentially instead of standing on the
picket line in solidarity with their
striking colleagues The Screen Actors
Guild call for industrial action on July
13th and some plastic surgeons in New
York and La have seen as much as a 30
percent increase in demand they're
saying with facelifts eye lifts and brow
lifts all at the top of the list or for
more on this supposed upsturge in Stars
Big Time producers and directors going
under the knife I'm joined by the
celebrity blog of Paris Hilton and the
Hollywood surgeon Ben Telle thank you
guys for joining me on this story and uh
Dr tale I'll come to you first because
when I first heard about this today
thought it seemed somewhat tangential uh
that strikes would lead to cosmetic
surgery but then when I read your
account it seems almost directly
correlated
yes interestingly um I it's not
something you think about day to day I'm
certainly not a strike leading to
surgery but uh this is something that
the pattern has kind of been building
since the pandemic occurred and shutdown
occurred and when the shutdown occurred
uh you saw just some just an outpour of
uh executive directors producers uh
writers actors and and it went to sports
figures singers and that kind of stuff
too coming in to get surgery because
they never had time to otherwise and
also what happened at the same time was
that whole zoom boom where people saw
their Tech necks they're always down on
their phone and they started to notice
the next so since that time people have
been waiting for one more pandemic or
one more shutdown to happen and it
wasn't happening and about four months
ago when the writers started talking
about maybe doing a strike the uh the
actors didn't know if they're going to
be a part of it then it turned out that
they looked historically and saw they do
better together and the second they saw
that they might strike all together is
when we started to get calls from actor
friends and Friends of their friends and
Friends calling in say hey do you mind
seeing this person for me there might be
a strike this is the only time they have
for a neck lift can you please get them
in so we've seen uh a lot over here in
La my friends in the other states hasn't
changed too much but over here in
Beverly Hills it's it's a pretty
interesting phenomenon you're making me
wonder if I've got 10 ethnic now
something I wasn't even worried I
thought I should be worried about Perez
listening to that obviously not taking
away from those striking on the picket
line but are you surprised to hear that
some people aren't and choosing cosmetic
surgery instead
what I'm surprised about is that we are
still striking
thankfully The producer's Guild is
sitting down at the table this Friday
with the writers and I hope the same
happens with the actors I am a member of
sag The Screen Actors Guild and while
some members might be getting cosmetic
procedure the overwhelming majority are
actually struggling to meet the
requirement to get health insurance as a
stag member so this isn't about
luxuries this is about livelihood and
surviving in fact so many big name
actors that were on huge shows for
Netflix spoke out recently not even
about the residuals problem but about
how little they were paid while making
their shows and of course there's the
big issue of AI and the future of
technology when it comes to actors so I
just want to stress the seriousness and
importance of this yeah I was actually
shocked looking at some of the figures
today of actors that have come out and
said they received almost a sense on the
dollar for residuals this means that
when their show that they filmed years
ago now gets franchised out onto Netflix
or whatever the royalties they're
getting offer are absolutely minimal
shockingly low amounts and I think
people attempted to think actors are
just spoiled and everyone lives in
luxury in LA but it's not the case is it
Perez
no you know and the requirement to get
health insurance in is 26 000 a year
so there's a lot of working actors whose
names you don't know who are going
without health insurance so that to me
is a big issue that hopefully is
addressed and of course the residuals
issue as well and just you know
respecting the talent we've seen
recently that actors promoting movies
can result in hundreds of millions of
dollars at the box office look at Barbie
on the flip side you saw the recent
release of the film The Flash and those
stars because the lead Ezra Miller was
mired in controversy none of those
actors for the most part promoted The
Flash Film and that was a major
disappointment at the box office the
studios need actors and need to respect
them
Dr tale coming back to you when you're
here uh and I know you've got friends in
the industry and you're very much based
over there as well is there a clear
delineation here between
um people acting in series the franchise
onto Netflix and those big a-listers or
even B listers that might be coming to
you
yeah so absolutely the A and B list the
ones that are very very well off
financially and
um don't worry about money at all those
are the ones getting surgery the friends
that I have that are doing the smaller
TV shows the writers everybody else they
are uh pinching every penny they
possibly can because they don't know how
long the strike's gonna go on for and
their livelihood really depends on it so
those people have actually stopped doing
Botox fillers the basic stuff and said
you know what I'm going to hold off on a
couple months uh until I know exactly
what's gonna happen so there's a huge
disparity between the two so the higher
end uh I'd say higher net worth uh
actors and people who are more
comfortable the ones that we've been
seeing the ones who are still struggling
or not fully comfortable uh they're not
doing anything right now yeah another
necessarily over intellectualize this
this being on screen as
get on screen as well you know it is
sort of part of the job to look good
otherwise people do point out when you
don't look good and things start to
wrinkle a bit or sag and the rest of it
could you argue then Dr tale that there
is a sort of requirement for plastic
surgery within acting I mean I mean I
might be sort of clutching at straws
here
uh no no you're not wrong it's for
everybody except for character actors so
there are character actors and age-based
actors that we see
um there are I know 30 year olds who
play high school students I know high
school students who want to be older but
they don't really get the jobs
um and you have character actors who
need to look old so but apart from them
everybody else uh they end up seeing the
changes over time and they lose the
character that they had that they want
to keep so you'd have somebody you know
as good looking as like Brad Pitt he's
known for his jawline he's known for his
neck he's known for these kind of things
and uh he's not so much known for the
different other characteristic parts of
him unfortunately and for someone like
that it would be a struggle and you'd
have to maintain that fit appearance or
looking kind of young looking like a
chiseled jawline and those kind of
things so there is a stress for them to
remain the same to keep getting the
roles that they want whereas there are
other actors who kind of evolve with the
age and go with the character and you'd
have you know someone like uh Eddie
almost Jr or um you know people like
that who have that characteristic
appearance that actually benefits them
so they don't want any plastic surgery
and they don't want to look any
different than they used to and they
want to age it's fascinating so I want
to end with Paris because Paris you
built your Empire uh on celebrity gossip
if I can call it that news watching
celebrities do you think culture has
changed with regards to the way that
people's appearance is critically
analyzed do you think people are more
accepting now celebrities getting
plastic surgery
well they are more accepting but I don't
think culture has changed that much to
be honest on the surface they would like
to say that ooh we're Kinder but people
on social media are a lot of Hypocrites
and they'll still leave really awful
comments on pictures and videos of
celebrities and that kind of criticism
does lead many to get work done and
sometimes to really uh
irreversible
effects you know some celebrities get
too much work done and it's really hard
to look like themselves
indeed they do and they do get called
out on it look Perez Dr Talley thank you
very much for making time to talk on
this
thank you my pleasure
well and censored next tonight have you
ever wanted to see a former prime
minister abandoned in the middle of a
jungle and made to do humiliating tasks
well if ITV get their way you might be
in luck my pack will be in here next
discuss the Liz trust I'm a celebrity
rumors and much more
[Music]
thank you
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City King peers and King
Cube I think it's only one for one king
he's mopped your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail stop working just cause
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
war but you're making me cry again
they're trying to force you out yes I
feel betrayed keep it award-winning
Keith Edwards has been revealed as the
presenter at the center of the BBC
Scandal he is the most important
television presenter on the BBC that we
pay for whatever torture he may have
been going through in that in some way
is an excuse yeah for what appears to be
an abuse of power when they first got
together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth because you're
not just marrying the man you're
marrying the job that resonates with
people Elaine Maxwell agreed to be
interviewed for the very first time I
obviously wish I'd never met him
the conservi party can certainly win the
next election yes
did you say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
all right
[Music]
if we stop producing oil the knock-on
effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I know you're probably going to
vote me off shorts
some of them they're easily LED
you can kiss my American Air thank you
very much very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you there's a
threat that you'd be worried about so
are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
what does a woman make
you weren't asked to give evidence to
the grand jury I'm the only one that has
Battalion materials you don't drink
never taken drugs you're stinking Rich
she 'll be concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
[Music]
coming up on the talk Donald Trump faces
his most serious charges yet with the
former president accused of spreading
lies and plotting to overturn the 2020
election plus labor warns up to 1500
criminals could avoid jail as Britain's
prisons reach bursting point and soap
staple Coronation Street is rocked by a
birthday cake Scandal that script
writers could only dream of that's all
at nine o'clock
[Music]
welcome back to uncensored with me
Rosanna Lockwood in the chair tonight
and still with me here in the studio
talk TV contributor Esther Krakow and
the associate editor of the Daily Mirror
Kevin McGuire joining us just to talk a
little lightness and you know what uh
let's start somewhere else first though
with lizzo uh I say lightness this is
actually quite dark yeah
and surprisingly uh because lizard of
course very popular performer she's
known for her body positivity she's a
very sort of liberal performer and she
has been accused of sexual harassment
and creating a hostile work environment
through sexual racial and religious
harassment several incidents between
2021 and 2023. that was according to a
lawsuit filed yesterday I was surprised
when I heard this uh I I fully believe
leaved Her Image I'm a big supporter of
her have been up to this point I think
because the allegations are really bad
Esther well yes but we have to remember
where these where she's being sued it's
this is the US a very litigious culture
and the second you're you're famous and
someone feels like they can get
something off you you're a Target I'm
not saying that this person's
allegations are not true but at the end
of the day I find it very hard to
believe that lizzo was fat shaming
anybody I mean Not only would it be
highly inappropriate uh for obvious
reasons also it would be very
inconsistent with the kind of message
that she puts out there like she's all
about body positivity and all of that I
mean some of the allegations in there
are pretty scaling I'm not going to lie
but I I I don't believe them yet I still
hold to the innocent until proven guilty
in Mantra yeah you think you think it's
all just drummed up to take lizzo down
no I I think it's it's inconsistent with
what we see of her that's what I'm
saying and I'm not surprised that this
is happening in a country where they
have a very intense litigious culture I
I look I've got an open mind on it uh
but I was surprised because of a
religion everything she's said but
sometimes people aren't their public
images I'm not saying that's the case
for her this has to be tested in court
but yeah by lawyers but there are three
claims I suspect it'll come down to what
corroboration there is and she's got a
big problem if uh if they're found to be
you know true because of that image
she's projected if she just projected a
scuzzy image and she was found
it wouldn't be look at that but it's
somebody who that is what I I when I
when I read the fat show me I was like
yeah no no but some of the details in a
you know a nightclub in this it's
criticized to dance weight gain and
later berated then fired that dancer for
recording a meeting and then according
to a lawsuit also encouraging one one
dollar to touch a new to perform at a
club in Amsterdam and subjected several
dances to an excruciating 12-hour
audition after making false accusations
they drank while working so it sounds
like there's going to be a few parties
corroborating well yeah I mean this is
the person that went to a basketball
game with her entire bum out you know
she wore those cut out trousers so
clearly uh I I don't think she's the
best you know I also just think the
judge there's a lesson in this about
about treating the people around you at
work well regardless of the role that
you hold which you see time and again
well look you can you can punch her but
you can't punch down yeah unless you can
hit the you know industry record
industry Executives you're the boss of
whoever a company is that's all right
that's fine but don't no not the other
people not your dancers there's not
people on Sound and Lighting let's talk
about lighter things it's silly season
and that's what we call it in news
anyway in August when parliament's in
races and there's not much political
news going on but there is some
political gossip that Liz truss could be
set for the I'm a celebrity jungle if
you can believe it now latest gossip was
that Boris Johnson had been approached
for this and had been offered I don't
know where this report's from around a
700 Grand to get into the jungle but
declined it now this gossip saying the
next Target is former prime minister
this trust uh other big name politicians
also being considered Dominic Robb a
Santa Javid or quasico I refuse to
believe it I refuse to believe it
because that would be so ludicrous on so
many levels Matt Hancock was on it that
is precisely the point but that's also
why the the makers of the program know
you get a politician you pay big bucks
yeah but the thing is I think but they
know Society with all due respect being
a politician is still a serious job
believe it or not and I think you
degrade your office when you do stuff
like this I think reality TV shouldn't
be on the agenda for any politician I
think it's humiliating politicians
you're disrespecting the public anyway
she couldn't last more than a week well
yeah there is the question whether she
will Outlast the time she was prime
minister which was 40.
get a letter saying instead get a
lettuce in the jungle uh talk about
humiliating politicians we don't like to
do it uh without cause on this show but
let's take a look at Richard's Sue next
trousers shall we this photo doing the
rounds yesterday oh lower strap is
covering the ankles let's see if we can
show you that the gap between the sock
of the trousers is causing some
consternation and online circles please
pull them up at the hip how can you pay
three and a half Grand on a suit and it
doesn't fit you hold on he's only five
foot six first of all we have to
consider the logistics here we don't
know all the proportions we don't know
all the dimensions we don't know
everything he's we don't know what
everything he's working with oh below
the belt we don't know any of that we
are not his tailors okay so let's just
assume to be gracious that he's pulled
them up a bit and that he's also a small
man
he's five foot six he's
[Applause]
whatever you're up to make sure it is
uncensored good night
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]